oh yeah so i had to do press for ontario
uh-huh
right so like it's it's it's one radio
station which is a good one
what's that called hamilton yeah
it's a great morning news show i've done
it before
but it's like five in the morning i'm
like i have to go to culver city and
then go straight from culver city to
ontario
to do shows and they got me a hotel room
so i could sleep all during the day
so at like five in the morning i called
abby abby was in new york
my manager and i go i can't do there's
no way i can do it
they're ready for you you know we said
you would you said you would do it
and i made a deal i go i'll go on the
next three auditions no matter what it
is
i'll go in physically if you get me out
of this
so she got me out damn so sometimes when
you talk to people you have to
give them you know you have to negotiate
you get to tell them deals and i'm a
deal maker
and imagine trying to make deals with a
deal maker
so what i have to do is i have to play
the game so if i want him
like last deal for instance if i
desperately want him to see a doctor
yeah i will i will make sure that
there's an audition that day that he
he wants to get out of and he so that
he'll be like okay
fine i'll rather go to the doctor yes
but i will fabricate an audition
so that he thinks that already a doctor
is a good deal
yeah do you know this that she's
fabricating yeah no she doesn't no i
don't no he doesn't here's the thing
though dude
he does because because i still believe
right that um
auditions and i i went out how many i
went on some film ones this year
yeah yeah i tested for that regency one
i went in there and i did that one other
one
i hope you read for that one yeah dc one
yeah i've sent someone
some it's just like you know it's not
i'm not getting any clothes
i'm not going any clothes and um you
know it disturbs me because
um you know people say all the time
[Music]
it's your time to me and i go
what do you mean and they go you know
because of crazy rich asians
and all these other things like being
asian
is hot right now but pop no one calling
papa
right and then when i talk to other ones
like the other ones like jimmy yo yang
or alex yeah oh yeah we got 15 movies
coming out
right yeah we got like every you know i
mean we got everything
yeah right and then you know i i look at
someone like joe coy and i
and margaret cho as too yeah
and i have to reiterate and stress
how important it was for someone like
margaret to hit the scene
when she hit it you know um
when i started not only were there no
auditions for asians
we couldn't even get stage time right in
the 90s
like there wasn't a lot and the ones
that here's the thing
asian comics before i started
a lot of them got up on stage only
because of the fact that they had an
accent
i mean or they you know
it wasn't necessarily they wrote jokes
to get laughed people would just laugh
at them
you're like like the old johnny yoon
thing i said when he his applause break
when he said hot
all right right so it was much harder
i'm not blowing steam up my ass i'm just
i just this is the reality
of it was [ __ ] difficult i don't
think anyone would argue with the fact
that but that's the thing it's like i
know but the thing is
that like but now that it's easy it's
hard
for me hey sorry to interrupt guys but
we have an amazing
sponsor
future in your pocket all day long
you guys uh the only wall
that i use yeah and i will forever use
is this it's called the ridge wallet
amazing right